[Music]
last month 42 year old eric smith was
released from prison after being locked
up for 28 years 48 hours has been
following this case since 1993 when
smith who was 13 years at the time
killed a four-year-old boy derek roby in
a fit of rage on this week's show
correspondent jim alcerad looks at the
controversial decision to let him go
free
we never forget
our boy
he was you know a wonderful child and we
miss him terribly
[Applause]
i wouldn't wish this on anyone
for almost three decades doreen and dale
roby have lived with the anguish of that
day in 1993. he says i love you mom and
he went hopping off the sidewalk
when they learned their adored little
boy had been lured into the woods
strangled and beaten with rocks
if that wasn't horrific enough his
killer was a red-headed freckle-faced
child
eric smith was tried as an adult
and convicted of murdering derrick roby
so you find the defendant guilty of
murder in the second degree yes
smith's sentence was nine years to life
take the young man in custody but it
would also be a life sentence for the
robies once smith became eligible for
parole in 2002
they could decide that well now he's
done his time and we're going to let him
go
every two years smith was back before
the board and the robies would have to
relive their son's murder and fight to
make sure his killer's parole was denied
it's not fair that we have to keep doing
this
the news the robies had been dreading
came after eric smith's 11th appearance
before the board
when he was finally granted parole
and as he told weny tv in 2009
he had big plans for his future i want
to you know get married
raise a family
pursue the american dream
about that tall john tunney who
prosecuted smith's case
says it's too early to know
if that'll happen at the end of the day
still a little bit of a gamble oh no no
it's a huge gamble
this parole decision is a high risk
enterprise to be sure
and you can see jim's report eric smith
gambling on a killer tomorrow night at
10 9 central right here on cbs and our
streaming service paramount plus